joining me now is rupert pierce an
intensive care doctor in a london
hospital and representing the intensive
care society very warm welcome to the
program to you and we hugely appreciate
you
taking the time out to speak to us here
on sky news
first of all your reaction to those
comments from the mayor of london there
i think the first thing is i'd like to
fully endorse the public health message
that sadiq khan has described that
we can control this virus if we follow
the rules
um and what i would like
people in london and across the country
to understand is that
the nhs is here for you we're dedicated
we're proud to be your nhs
but right now we need to control this
virus so we've got the bandwidth to look
after all patients who need our care
not just patients with covert we're
being told that the number of patients
on ventilators has doubled in the
capital since
christmas day just tell us a little bit
about what you're seeing
in intensive care at the moment
so we're opening up more and more
intensive care beds all the time
and we're pulling in staff from other
areas to allow us to do that
our most precious resource in intensive
care is our intensive care nurses who
are incredibly highly trained
and who are the final common pathway of
delivery of all the intensive care
treatments the ventilators the dialysis
machines and all the drugs that we use
right now we're having to dilute as we
say that that expertise to one trained
nurse for three
patients and being pushed to go even
further to one nurse to four
patients in some places and and that
means that we're having to fill those
gaps with
staff who aren't trained as intensive
care nurses in some cases they're
medical students or nurses from other
areas
and even in even hospital consultants
coming from other areas of practice to
help us deliver patient care
now you can understand that means those
staff aren't available to do their usual
jobs
and that means other areas of patient
care which is less urgent is going to
suffer
so let's be frank about it then the
standard of care unfortunately
is much poorer at the moment and of
course we're not even talking about
those people
presenting in intensive care or indeed
uh accident and emergency with
non-covert problems
so one of the most remarkable things
i've seen this year
is the absolute determination of nhs
staff to deliver the best
possible quality care they can but i
think it's obvious to anybody but our
ability to do that
is being stretched to the absolute limit
and and so it does become very difficult
i think the area of quality that's most
affected right now
is the fact that we're so focused on
patients with emergency problems
that we're not able to do as much of the
planned care
that we need to do so things like
outpatient clinics and elective
surgeries are not happening in the way
that they normally would
and those are people who need patient
care as well how is the situation in
intensive care comparable to
the last peak we heard the mayor of
london describing it
according to some of the practitioners
he'd spoken to has been comparable to a
theater of war
there are lots of war analogies you
could use about my experience
this year in terms of uh how our lives
have changed and the uncertainty that
we're experiencing
i think the biggest difference between
the first wave and the second wave for
me
is just how long it's lasting in the
first wave we went from very few cases
to a peak
within two three four weeks this
second wave has been going on and on and
on since early november late october
and it doesn't look like it's going to
stop until at the end of january
if we're lucky and just maintaining this
response for that period of time is
proving absolutely exhausting for nhs
staff
and we hear from colleagues and people
like you describing when they go home
many of them are unable to sleep money
many of them suffering from ptsd
may i ask you how you're coping how your
colleagues are feeling at the moment
how's morale
um morale is often high if you come into
hospital you'll see staff
smiling and looking after each other and
looking out for each other
the the problem comes with resilience we
each
get a hit something bad happens
something that makes us feel sad
maybe a crossword that wasn't intended
and and those things hit us much harder
than they are normally
and and people are going home as you say
you know finding it hard to sleep
finding it very hard to relax and that
means they're still tired when they get
up the next day to go back to work
and just a final thought for from you
about those people not just the people
who've blatantly
broken the rules perhaps partied outside
hospitals in the capitol but perhaps
those people who tune in and
watch the prime minister announcing that
households shouldn't mix
over christmas and then continued to do
so what would your
uh sentiment be towards those people and
anyone who continues to think that they
are above the rules
well i would say we're all in this
together i have to socially distance too
i'm in lockdown to all of my family are
my kids are being homeschooled i my
father in laura's uh had his major
cardiac surgery delayed
the experiences of this are the same for
the nh staff nhs staff as everybody else
but the solution to this pandemic is
within all of our control if we come
together
as a team we can control this virus like
we did in the first wave
if we follow the government rules in
terms of the lockdown
and and and just stay at home where we
can but perhaps one of the most
important things
is families shouldn't get together in
each other's houses one of the worst
places for transmission of this virus
is families getting together in in
different houses
that matters just as much as mingling in
the high street or in shops
rupert pearce intensive care doctor
please know how grateful we all
are for all the hard work that you're
doing and your colleagues and we wish
you the very best
through this very difficult time thank
you